I was born in Iran
I've witnessed ballistic missiles coming
down that made me think that okay what
are the things that I would like to
change what are the things that I would
like to impact and at the end of the day
I think we need to be responsible for
using any technology in a positive
fashion if there's anyone out there that
could steer the thrust of technology
away from our own demise and toward the
betterment of humanity this could be the
guy my name is Ali Hodja Miri I am an
educator and an engineer and an inventor
this very young age I was really curious
to find out how things work any kind of
toy I had I you know within a couple of
days it was ripped apart and opened in
two hundred pieces and you know my
parents were not a huge fan of that but
throughout the process I tried to then
build things myself at some point I
tried to make a laser when I was I think
about 10 or 11 and I didn't succeed but
hajimari made up for that failure in his
adult life today
he holds more than 90 issued patents and
along with his tenure at Caltech carries
a reputation of making ideas that would
otherwise sound like science fiction a
reality things that I work on or some of
the inventions if you will that we've
been involved in they span a large gamut
lensless cameras lenses projections and
3d cameras radar on a chip self-healing
circuits hand-held diagnostic devices
wireless power transfer space-based
solar power they may appear kind of
seemingly unrelated to each other but
they all rely on this underlying concept
of the phased array the phased arrays is
basically a large number of small
elements working together has Ramirez
inspiration for phased array technology
comes from an unlikely place
yes as a child I took a big jar of glass
jar and you know I was digging through
an intense and hell and then I took a
whole bunch of ants and just dumped them
in that jar and within a couple of days
they started building the whole nest it
was really amazing because it showed how
you can achieve very complex things
through interactions of simple units the
phased arrays is basically the army of
ants
[Music]
now instead of ants carrying dirt
imagine millions of tiny signals working
in concert to send energy wirelessly
this phased array system is the basis
for hedgy Mary's latest and most
ambitious project collecting solar power
in outer space and beaming it down to
earth we are in the wireless power
transfer laboratory and we are looking
at a set up for demonstration and
testing of a wireless power transfer
here you have a small version of what
would be collecting power we are
basically creating a beam and focusing
of the energy in this location and what
you can see is that energy is being
transferred wirelessly and this would be
the unit building block of making the
space-based generator power station this
is an extremely important thing because
first of all it gives access globally to
energy and power it doesn't introduce
any greenhouse gases or any of that sort
in the process of making of the energy
but the idea of sending power to earth
from space
has some pretty high-profile detractors
space solar power
okay the stupidest thing ever skeptics
like Elon Musk believe that after
multiple power conversions and the cost
of launches and the sheer scale of such
a project makes it far too expensive and
inefficient forever trapping it within
the confines of science fiction and if
anybody should think it should like say
solar power it should be me alright I
got I got a rocket company and a solar
company
but this is of little concern to a man
who has made his living defying
conventional wisdom he believes that the
greatest innovations come from an active
imagination a lot of us are inspired by
science fiction I think science fiction
is essential to the way of thinking
about making useful and interesting
things so you start with a concept that
doesn't exist that could have been
articulated in science fiction and you
try to see what can you do about that
can you do it in an entirety can you do
a variation of that and that process
that's part of the creative process
right I mean engineering is their
discipline of creativity the key
question is that how can you make it in
such a way that it's feasible and also
economical and to do that you have to
take a lot of different kinds of
technologies and bring them together
like an army of ants all working
together at the unlikely intersection of
science fiction and reality you know
nothing is done in isolation no one
person really in today and I think ever
was doing things by themselves you know
if you want to go fast go alone if you
want to go far take your friends
[Music]
you
you